[Music]
sarah's with us in austin texas hi sarah
welcome to the ramsay show
hey how are you guys great how can we
help
well my husband and i found us a month
ago and i want to thank you guys for
lighting a fire under
us when i was 18
i was ready to get out of the house and
i applied for colleges
i toured many but my mother told me that
if i didn't go to this certain one
i wouldn't go so that put me in debt
about
forty six thousand my husband and i he's
in a doctorate program for
uh physical therapy is about 150 and
that would be our debt i want to break
the legacy of my family i'm the first
woman in
my family to graduate college and i want
to continue growing that legacy with no
debt
and just being wealthy and when it comes
down to it
i'm just angry at my mother and i feel a
moral obligation to pay my student loans
but i selfishly
don't feel like it's all on me and i
just need advice
and you probably telling me that i'm
being a selfish brat
i wouldn't say that it's how i feel kind
of
yeah i understand um
what's your household income
right now it would be
we make about 44
um a month not forty four thousand forty
four hundred a month
and my husband will be making more he
graduates in december but he's in school
full time right now
okay and he's gonna be getting a degree
in what
physical therapy okay so he'll be making
70 or 80 grand
yeah right okay and so you're gonna go
from a fifty thousand dollar income
to a hundred and twenty thousand dollar
income and you got 180 000
between you and student loan debt does
your mom have a lot of money no
okay no
so what part of you being mad at her
makes her have money
because she had money she can't pay this
even if she wanted to right
so here's what we agreed on and maybe
this is why
i'm mostly upset with her is because she
said that she would be
paying off the loans for i guess the
rest of her life and because i was
18 i didn't even think about it and i
was like okay sure yeah
so i got married and so i just didn't
even think about my student loans being
a part of my debt and so i was talking
to her because we're
having to move for his clinicals
was basically saying so whenever uh you
know you guys get higher paying jobs you
can you know start paying off your debt
and she's right it just makes me angry
because i didn't even want to so she
forgot the part where she promised to
pay it
exactly yeah and that does make you
angry and
she in her ignorance given that she did
not go to college you said
she drove you to go to a college that
you really couldn't afford yeah
yeah i mean it was a private christian
school so it was
ridiculously expensive and let me and if
i heard this thing correctly your
husband is still in school right
and so he has about three months left
right so i'm honestly i'm not even
worried about paying back my mom just
yet
that's not even a consideration it's not
her mom she has a student loan i mean
yes
so here's my thing i'm focusing on
getting my husband out of school without
racking up any more debt
right that's what i'm gonna focus on but
when they graduate should she go to her
mom to have her mom
pay for this uh if her mom said
yes i'm going to talk to my dad and my
parents like hey listen
this is what we we agreed upon you know
um
don't change now because you know i've
been able to
uh up my income i'm having a serious
respectful but firm conversation
because this is not what we it's not
what we agreed to do
uh but yes i'm i'm having a conversation
but outside of that if she says no dave
she's
i mean you're gonna have to pay for it
yeah i would be prepared to pay for it
how old are you i just turned 25.
okay um
i kind of think i'm hearing between the
sentences
that this behavior
of inconsistency with your mom is a
pattern more than just a singular event
oh yeah oh yeah so it's kind of like
it's kind of like that part of it's kind
of like that part of growing up where
you look over and you realize
my mom's really not right on some of
these things
you know that part of that part of where
you grow up and you realize my parents
really
are not yeah and then you go okay i'm
going to let them be parents anyway i'm
still going to forgive them and move on
i i don't think your mom has forty
thousand dollars so i don't think the
discussion matters much
except it just hurts your feelings
yeah i'm afraid you're right yeah i'm
not saying you're a brat i think you
have a valid reason she made you a
promise that she didn't keep
and led you astray uh because
but it wasn't out of malice she didn't
you know let's move my daughter deeply
in debt and run her life she didn't that
was not her goal
her goal was she did the best she could
do recommending that
school because she had never been to
school and she thought that was the best
way to do it
right so her she was an enthusiastic
ignoramus
yeah but i mean she was not was not
malice she certainly didn't set out to
hurt you agreed
right for sure yeah she just she just
didn't know what she was doing because
you're first generation college
and that's that's where we run into the
most student loan debt anthony i've
talked about this a lot
it's both uh it's socio-economic but
it's uh it's regional it's racial
it's a lot of things we see it in all
the demographics when we study the
student loan stuff
but it's any time uh regardless of what
area of the country
your biggest mistakes in what the field
of study is and where you go to school
and how much student loan debt you go
into
are the parents trying to go i didn't
get an education you got to get one i
have no idea how to do it but education
is everything and everybody goes and
overspends
for the wrong thing and that this first
generation college
does it the worst that's the ones that
get screwed over the most
and uh so that's where you are you kind
of fit in that thing
huh i i think the best route
for where do you end up with the best
life for you
at 30 i don't think she can pay it
i don't think you holding her to it is
gonna cause anything to change in her
yeah and so probably just a good
relationship with your mom
and call it and just go this sucks and
i'm going to pay it
i'm going to get rid of it i don't think
i'm going to bother her with it because
i don't think she can pay it
and i don't think she set out to harm
you at all
she just didn't know what the flip she
was doing and so
and she's a little ditzy and a little
bit doesn't follow through and that's
aggravating and i get that
but i just let her be mom and move on
this is the ramsey show